Orlando Bloom in an interview with Elle
UK the 40 year old explains his full
monty saying he thought he and Katie had
escaped the cameras quote I have a good
radar we've been completely alone for
five days there was no way anyone could
get anything so I had a moment of
feeling free what can I tell you note to
self
you're never free ha
as for how our Linden feels about his ex
Katie he says quote we're friends it's
good we're all grown up it's better to
set an example for kids a show that
prick ups don't have to be about hate
but breakups may be what lead to a new
look five weeks ago platinum died Katie
got a pixie cut and last night she went
even shorter buzzing almost all of it
off the only thing left to do is like
shave my head which I'm really saving
for a public breakdown I'm down for that
I don't know get this moment away from
that well it's not shaved but it's
getting pretty close
[Music]
and does new hair equal new guy Katie
responded to the rumor that she's
hooking up with Ryan Philippi Sunday
Reese Witherspoon's seriously hot axe
tweeted I am NOT dating Katy Perry
barely know her
please stop flying helicopters over my
house she is not here thanks
the 32 year old Katy replied quote can
you let me out of this basement please
followed by hi nice to meet you sorry
about that Ryan Philippine carry on lol
[Music]
I mean if she just looks at a man the
rumors start flying
I still like a read on mayor
[Music]